Not For the First Time Scotland Yard
targeted over a criminal within its
ranks
senior officers admitted they ignored
warnings about a colleague a rapist in
uniform
we can't rely on the police to
perform violence against
Society if the police are perpetrators
who can get away with this stuff with
impunity how can we feel safe
for 18 years PC David Carrick attacked
vulnerable women he told them I'm a
police officer you'll be safe with me if
they complained he warned them they'd
never be believed
after first pleading not guilty Carrick
appeared in court to admit 49 charges 24
of them were rapes
this man Abused Women and the most
disgusting manner not only have we let
down the women in this case the
survivors who've courageously come
forward
I completely recognize that's going to
be the reaction of many women across
London indeed more widely
all I can say is I'm sorry I'm sorry
that we've let you down today the
victims who suffered at the hands of
David Carrick have finally seen Justice
it is their courage in standing up
against this heinously abusive man a
police officer that has helped to secure
his conviction
ultimately breaking his power and
control over women
in 2001 David Carrick joined the
Metropolitan Police he'd been vetted a
year later he was accused of harassing
an ex-partner no action was taken
over the next six years he raped several
women
in 2016 another harassment complaint in
Hampshire no action was taken he
continued to rape and abuse women the
next year he was vetted again and passed
in 2019 he allegedly assaulted a woman
in Hertfordshire he got a mild reprimand
and the matter was dropped
two years ago a woman said he raped her
he was arrested the victim chose not to
proceed and no action was taken Carrick
continued to serve as a metropolitan
police officer three months later he was
arrested and charged with another rape
and suspended twelve more victims
contacted police
this appalling incident represents a
breach of trust will it will affect
people's confidence in the police and
it's clear that standards and culture
need to change
the Met has been hit by recent scandals
at Charing Cross police station officers
swapped racist and sexist text messages
but a murder scene officers took
pictures of the bodies of Two Sisters
technically David Carrick is still a
serving police officer but he hasn't
been paid since last month when he
admitted the first of the charges
against him in the morning he faces a
fast-track disciplinary hearing to sack
him
the Met said it was already tightening
up its vetting process and trying to
reach out bad offices
it was confident that today David
Carrick would never get a job as a
policeman
Martin brunt Sky News